so you've talked about humans as special
how exactly are we special relative to
the dinosaurs so i mentioned that
there's um you know this dramatic
cognitive
improvement that we've made but i think
it goes
much deeper than that so if you look at
a lion
attacking a gazelle in the middle of the
serengeti
the lion is smelling the molecules in
the environment
it's uh
hormones and neuroreceptors are sort of
getting it ready for impulse
the target is constantly looking around
and sensing
i've actually been in kenya and i've
kind of
seen the hunt yes i've kind of seen the
sort of game of waiting
and the mitochondria in the muscles
of the lion are basically ready for
you know jumping they're
expensing an enormous amount of energy
the grass as it's flowing
is constantly transforming solar energy
into chloroplasts you know through the
chloroplast into
energy which eventually feeds the
gazelle and eventually feeds
the lions and so forth so as
humans we experience all of that
but the lion only experiences
one layer the mitochondria in its body
are only experiencing one layer the
chloroplasts are only experiencing one
layer
the you know photoreceptors and the
smell receptors the chemical receptors
like the lion always attacks against the
wind
so that it's not smelled like
all of these things are
one layer at a time and we humans
somehow perceive the whole stack
so going back to software infrastructure
and hardware infrastructure
if you design a computer you basically
have a physical layer that you start
with
and then on top of that physical layer
you have you know the electrical
layer and on top of the electrical layer
you have basically gates
and logic and an assembly layer and on
top of the assembly layer you have your
you know higher order higher level
programming
and on top of that you have your deep
learning routine etc and on top of that
you eventually build
a cognitive system that's smart
i want you to now picture this cognitive
system
becoming not just self-aware
but also becoming aware of the hardware
that it's made of
and the atoms that there that it's made
of and so forth
so it's as if your ai system and there's
this beautiful scene
in um uh 2001 obviously of space
where where uh how after dave starts
disconnecting him yes
he's starting to sing a song about
daisies etc
and hal is basically saying dave
i'm losing my mind i can feel
i'm losing my mind it's just so
beautiful
this concept of self-awareness of
knowing that the hardware is no longer
there is amazing
and in the same way humans who have had
accidents
are aware that they've had accidents so
there's this self-awareness of ai
that is you know this beautiful concept
about
you know sort of the eventual cognitive
leap
to self-awareness but imagine now the ai
system
actually breaking through these layers
and saying wait a minute i think i can
design a slightly better hardware
to get me functioning better and that's
what basically humans are doing
so if you if you look at our reasoning
layer it's built on top of a cognitive
layer
and the reasoning layer we share with ai
it's kind of cool
like there is another thing on the
planet that can integrate equations
and it's man-made but we share
computation with them
we share this cognitive layer of playing
chess we're not alone anymore
we're not the only thing on the planet
that plays chess now we have a
i that also plays chess but in some
sense that that particular organism ai
as it is now
only operates in that layer exactly
exactly
and then most animals operate in the
sort of
cognitive layer that we're all
experiencing a bat
is doing this incredible integration of
signals
but it's not aware of it it's basically
constantly
sending echo location
waves and it's receiving them back and
multiple bats in the same cave
are operating at slightly different
frequencies and with slightly different
pulses
and they're all sensing objects and
they're doing motion planning
in their cognitive hardware but they're
not even aware of all of that
all they know is that they have a 3d
view of space around them
just like any gazelle walking through
you know the desert
and any baby looking around
is aware of things without doing the
math of how am i processing
all of these visual information et
cetera you're just aware of the layer
that you live in
i think if you look at this
at humanity we've basically managed
through our cognitive layer
through our perception layer through our
senses layer through our
multi-organ layer through our genetic
layer
through our molecular layer through our
atomic layer through our quantum layer
through even the very fabric of the
space-time continuum
unite all of that cognitively so as
we're watching that scene in the
serengeti
we as scientists we as educated humans
we as
you know anyone who's finished high
school are aware of all of this
beauty of all of these different layers
interplaying together
and i think that's something very unique
in perhaps not just the galaxy but maybe
even the cosmos
this species that has managed to
in space cross through these layers from
the enormous to the infinitely small and
that's what i love about
particle physics the fact that it
actually unites
everything they're very small the very
very small and the very big it's only
through the very big that the
very small gets formed like basically
every atom of gold
results from the fusion that happened
of you know increasingly large particles
before that explosion that then
disperses it through the cosmos
and it's only through understanding the
very large that we understand very small
and vice versa
and that's in space then there's the
time direction as you are
watching the kilimanjaro mountain you
can kind of
look back through time to when that
volcano was exploding and
you know growing out of the tectonic
forces
as you drive through death valley you
see these mountains
on their side and these layers
of history exposed
it we are aware of the
eons that have happened on earth and the
tectonic movements on earth
the same way that we're aware of the big
bang
and the you know early evolution of the
cosmos and we can also see forward in
time
as to where the universe is heading we
can see you know apophis
in 2068 coming over looking ahead in
time i mean that would be magician stuff
you know in ancient times so what i love
about humanity and its role in the
universe
is that you know if there's a god
watching
he's like finally somebody figured it
out i've been
building these beautiful things and
somebody can appreciate it and figured
me out
with god's perspective meaning like
become aware of yeah you know
yeah so it's kind of interesting so to
think of the world in this way as layers
and us humans are able to what convert
those layers into
ideas that they you can then like
combine
right so we're doing some kind of
conversion exactly
exactly
you